in many ways Halloween is the last
carnival left in the West it is in many
ways a modern holiday although it takes
its roots in ancient holidays as well
and so I want to look at Halloween
especially as someone who grew up in a
Christian home there was a lot of
controversy about Halloween whether or
not Christians had celebrated and what
exactly it meant and so I think that
that controversy is actually part of its
meaning and so we're going to look at
Halloween the different practices that
are being done in the modern time and
look at what it is exactly they might be
telling us symbolically what they might
be telling us about the world
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so Halloween the way it is practiced now
is mostly an American holiday although
it does have its roots in an Irish
culture in some English culture and also
in Catholic culture from before but in
them in the modern form most of us most
of the people who'll be watching this
video will know what it looks like it's
a night where all the houses are
decorated in a garish manner in terms of
frightening decorations tombs vampires
death monsters all the stuffs cobwebs
witches all the the most cliche version
of what is frightening to a human person
who are brought together in this evening
and then usually what happens is people
will children especially will dress up
in costumes adults it seems do that as
well and they'll play frightening games
they will watch frightening movies and
ultimately it all comes together in
trick-or-treating which means that the
children will dress up as monsters
there's all kinds of things and we'll go
from house to house and ask for candy by
saying trick-or-treat if the person
gives them a treat then the monsters go
away and if they don't in theory they
get a trick but of course of course
nobody does that anymore but that's the
narrative that's the story at least that
we understand is being told and so I
want to look at each element and talk
about the history of it a little bit in
terms of why it's taking the form it is
as I've said before and many of my
interpretations we have to be careful
and in thinking that just because we
discover the history the historical
causes of something that somehow we have
discovered its meaning the historical
causes of something can help us
understand the meaning of something but
it doesn't end there and so one of the
big controversies that is held both on
the kind of neo-pagan side and the
fundamentalist christian side
is that Halloween is a residue of an
ancient Celtic holiday so Wayne which
was celebrated at the same time and
there's something very interesting about
that because it coincides this ancient
feast of Satan would coincide pretty
much around the mid between the
equinoxes these fall equinoxes and the
solstices so kind of midpoint between
the equinoxes and the solstices and so
what you can understand is that with the
equinoxes we reach this kind of 50/50
day and so it's like this last moment
and then after that the days start to
get shorter and shorter moving towards
the Solstice and so halfway between that
is the moment where we really would
notice that the days are getting shorter
everything is getting cooler the leaves
are changing in certain parts of the
world especially here in in Canada the
leaves probably already are starting the
leaves are starting to fall around the
time of Halloween and so it really makes
sense that this feast would be connected
at least in Western Europe to the feast
of the all hallowtide we call it in the
Catholic Church it was called all
hallowtide people some people still
celebrated today it's three days of
celebrations there's All Hallows Eve
which has come to become Halloween then
there's all Saints Day and then there's
also 'ls Day and what it is basically is
a day to commemorate the dead and so we
have the eve of the feast then we have
the main feast which is All Saints Day
which is prayer to all the saints and
then there's a later holiday which was
added which is all souls day which was a
day to pray for all the dead and so what
we have is this moment where all these
let's say images of death were kind of
brought together praying for praying to
the saints praying for the dead but also
in terms of Western Europe the seasons
are trying to starting to change things
are getting cooler and so there's an
element of death
which is missing you can see the things
Rick coming together you can you can see
all these images of death coming
together but there's an aspect of death
which is missing and that would be the
more we could call them the more
negative aspects of death or a an
understanding or participation in the
negative aspects of the dark fringes
that darkness on the corner which is
equivalent and related or at least
related to death all those negative
emotions like fear like horror all these
things which we associate with death and
so it is inevitable that at least in the
folk tradition that some thing would
happen that something would come
together at that time to celebrate let's
say or at least remember the darker
aspects of this feast of death we could
call it and in this idea of let's say
celebrating the feasts of death it's not
completely irrelevant to think that it
is partly or largely this celebration of
death is related to a remembering in a
resident in a decomposed manner a
remembering of pre-christian Europe that
there are some strains of pre-christian
Europe which would appear in this kind
of remembering of death because the
notion of something which came before of
a world that came before our present
world is also extremely related to death
to the margin to the monster I've talked
about this before in several of my talks
how that which precedes our origin is
usually portrayed as a monster which is
why you have these mythical stories of
heroes that come in to a new land and
chase away the monsters chase away
cannibals or months that you know dogged
in men or all these kind of monstrous
creatures and that's why you know on the
on the edge of the world
you have this idea that the titans are
there these horrible monstrous gods you
know in in Greek mythology but that
these titans proceed
the order of olympus so this is how the
world works when something replaces
something else that which was there
before becomes a kind of residue becomes
I could decomposing corpse and it
becomes related to death it's for the
same reason that the same reason that
Chris that the Greeks portray the Titans
as being these dark monstrous forces on
the edge then Christians portray the
ancient gods as being these demons on
the edge and the reason why they do that
is because that's what they are that's
what they become because a new story is
established and that which was before no
longer connects to the new story and so
when we see those things they don't
fully fit in the story and they appear
to us as monstrous as decomposing as
residues we could call them and so it's
not completely strange to imagine that
the Halloween holiday especially in that
moment where there's a celebration of
death we would see aspects of the the
residues of the ancient religions pop up
and so even if it's not the case even if
it's a purely Christian holiday the very
fact that people say that the very fact
that people latched on to that as a
narrative shows you the structure of how
the world lays itself out and so we have
this celebration of death and what does
it look like what are the elements that
are part of the part of Halloween now
one of the first things of course is the
basic notion of all these monsters that
come out you know the vampires the
ghosts the ghouls all of this coming out
of monsters in the form of storytelling
in the form of watching movies in the
form of costume people all of these
monsters are coming out now the thing
about ghosts and monsters and a lot of
these creatures is that they they're not
fully embodied creatures they're they're
somewhat more on the print side of
principalities and so they need what we
could call secondary causes to manifest
themselves they don't manifest
themselves on their own and so you
actually need move
and novels and and people to dress up in
these things for them to appear to us
because they're not they're not they're
not bodies the same way they don't have
bodies the same way we have bodies they
there are subtle beings you could call
them hopefully that makes sense and
you're not taking it in a science
fiction way when one day I'll explain
more about subtle bodies and and and all
that and how it makes sense but just to
say that these beings they they manifest
themselves through through these these
secondary causes like like the costumes
like the stories like the big giant
vampire that you put up in your window
you know like the the hanging ghost that
you put up to decorate your house all
these things are how these monsters at
this point manifest themselves in our
world and so make sense of course to
think of this time when darkness is
becoming more and more apparent where
death is becoming more and more apparent
in nature that you would get it's like
you know once that when the light is not
strong enough then the darkness starts
to take form the darkness starts to
manifest itself let's say from below you
could you could say something like that
like it starts to it starts to appear
from below and the way to get rid of
that is of course to pray and that's why
we pray to the Saints that's why we pray
for the dead that's the way to solve
Halloween ok the problem that we have
right now is that we only celebrate
Halloween and nobody celebrates or
almost nobody celebrates the second part
it's just like everybody's you know
still a lot of people will celebrate
Mardi Gras but nobody does lend it so
it's a sad sign of our society that the
only thing left of this this hallowtide
is the monstrous part whereas the prayer
part which is the way to get rid of the
monsters isn't there anymore but
nonetheless let's still we can still go
through the elements and to help you
understand why they manifest themselves
that way so now the notion of
trick-or-treating is very important in
terms of under
standing this problem the problem of
death or the problem of things which
come from the margins and start to
manifest themselves the problem the
question is how do you deal with them
you know because strange things that
come from the edge and they come to your
door now you have to decide do you let
them in a little bit do you let them in
completely or do you chase them away and
you have to realize that if you chase
them away then a horde can come towards
you you have to watch out Christ talks
about that by the way he says he talks
about the person who chases away the
demons and then sweeps his sweeps his
house you know and then and then all the
hordes have even come and find a nice
clean place to inhabit and so you have
to be very careful when you chase away
the demons a good example of that is
someone who for example will want to
diet extremely and so because of that
they'll impose on themselves an insanely
strict diet and then what will happen is
that they'll swing between an insanely
strict diet and binging and so that's
what happens when you you you're not
careful when you chase away the demons
it's the same thing with all those
passions that come to you and it's the
same thing with strangers as well if you
are hostile to strangers completely then
those strangers will see you as hostile
and maybe they'll come and rob your
house so what is the right way to deal
with it and and the right way to deal
with it is to find the balance of
hospitality and the balance that is
found in the trick-or-treating is the
monsters come out to the door right you
don't let them into your house you keep
them on the porch and then you give them
a little something so that they go away
a little treat just so that they go away
it's called placating demons and a lot
of people will say oh it's horrible
because that's what pagans do pagans
placate demons you know and the
that's what all these shamanistic
religions do they play care demons and
the truth is that's what they do but the
problem is that you placate demons all
the time we always plague a demon that's
what you know every time you smoke that
cigarette every time you masturbate
every time you you know eat that second
piece of cake what are you doing
you are placating the demon all right
you are giving a little bit of candy so
that the demon will go away at least for
a while and so obviously that is not the
best way to deal with that and that's
why Halloween has has that first little
kind of remembering of death and the
vicissitudes of death you could say and
then it has all saints and all all All
Souls because the answer to the problem
of Halloween is prayer now I'm not
saying that you shouldn't celebrate
Halloween and they're not saying you
should celebrate Halloween
you should understand why all those
things are lined up the way that they
are it makes sense and so in the
Halloween you have all the kind of
negative or the marginal aspects are
used in the feast so apotropaic imagery
is use you know instead of having
gargoyles on the outside of the church
you put gargoyles in front of your house
so you're using death to chase away
death you're using these frightening
husks of of the harvest and you are
trying to frighten away the monsters
frighten away the but yeah but at the
same time you're also attracting them at
the same time that is the ambivalent
problem of a potro paying practices you
could call them and so that is the basic
of Halloween but you also have to think
of Halloween really as a carnival in the
sense that you know like it's the the
placating of demons that's a bit what
carnival is in general it's this moment
where we let in a little bit of
inversion a little bit of madness a
little bit of darkness in order to not
completely give ourselves to it at some
later point and so
when you're wearing a costume that is
also something that's happening you
don't necessarily realize it but often
when you choose a costume you are in a
way venting some little aspect of
yourself
you know especially those that dress up
as monsters and all this kind of more
scary stuff and the lady is dressing up
in the sexy stuff it's all about venting
the venting that little part of you that
you've been bottling up and you and
giving one day for it to kind of come
out a little bit and then putting it
aside so it does have everything that
the carnival has is in Halloween so we
have to be attentive because one of the
things that something like Halloween can
show you about someone is can reveal a
hidden side about that person imagine
for example that you have a day where
you're allowed to let loose a little bit
where you're allowed to go over the
limit just a little and so what it does
is can actually show you something of
the darkness that winds inside you
because some people will go over the
line way too much will exaggerate we'll
get into the aesthetics of Halloween to
an extent in which they're so completely
immersed in it they they spend hours and
hours dressing up as some demon or some
zombie and they spend hours and hours
decorate you know days decorating their
houses in order or people who have
haunted houses in their houses and what
it does is it can actually show you what
priorities people have and so I would
also say if you're going to celebrate
Halloween be attentive to yourself and
to how much you let yourself go on a day
like that how far do you go into the
aesthetics of Halloween and maybe to be
slightly wary of someone who
themselves in something like Halloween
now the question that of course I said I
won't answer maybe I'm gonna answer it
anyways the question of course of why
should we or shouldn't we celebrate how
the week is Halloween somewhat dangerous
the answer is of course yes all those
images of monsters and witches and
everything they are my images of death
there are images of all those things
that can devour us on the edge and so is
it dangerous to engage with that the
answer is yes the other answer is what
happens if you don't engage with that at
all
that is also dangerous and so I think
that each person especially as
Christians have to find balance with
that have to understand that that there
you will have to deal with your demons
you will have to and you will placate
them no matter what you think do you
think you're not placating your demons
then you are living in an imaginary
world and so you will do that and so
this feast the feast of Halloween is a
small moment where we can at least
understand the structure of that we can
participate it in a kind of celebratory
way in order for us to see how it works
and then hopefully then we will also
know that in the original Halloween
there is the answer which is prayer and
prayer is the answer the ultimate answer
to your demons but in the manner in
which is celebrated in most people's
experience there is because it's in a
manner also a kind of laughing a death
that's what I told my kids I said one of
the aspects of Halloween is that here we
are we're looking outside we're seeing
the days get darker and darker we're
noticing that the Sun is going away and
so the question is is that it is it
going to end is the Sun gonna go forever
and then we know the answer the answer
is no it's not it's coming back it's a
ruse it's a trick all of this is it's
not an illusion
but it's a temporary thing and
ultimately spring will return and the
world will live again and so there's
something appropriate about laughing at
death in that moment - to make fun of
the power of death because we know that
it has lost its power long time ago and
and whatever power it has is the one we
give to it ourselves so I'm going to for
October this year I said I was also
going to give some some descriptions of
some monsters and so you'll see them in
the next in the next few weeks until
Halloween and I will also leave one of
the interpretations I still haven't
decided which one is going to be held
for the patron only video so I will keep
all of you keep you informed on that I
hope you enjoyed my video on Halloween I
want to give a quick shout out to Omid
Pakman you might have noticed that I put
up a new opening for my videos Omid
reached out to me and graciously put it
together
he's an animator who does all kinds of
great stuff special effects you can
check out his website in the description
and tell me what you think of the new
opening in the comments section I also
also want to remind everybody that I
will be in Chicago on the weekend of the
26th and the 27th the 26 in the evening
at 7:00 and as Jon conscience Catholic
Church in downtown Chicago and also at
the same church on Sunday morning after
liturgy after the the mass I will be
giving a short talk there as well I will
also meet in Pennsylvania the
the weekend of the second and third at
Santa con seminary if you want to come
and see me you can come to the liturgy
at Santa cons on Sunday in the morning
and I will be giving a quick Q&A and
having some discussion with you guys
after the liturgy on Sunday so hopefully
I can meet you there and the guys thanks
again for all your support and I will
see everybody soon